I don't care about having even one more
new follower why do I need another one I
don't know the people who are following
me people want to consume less we don't
want to spend as much time on social so
we want to follow us how many people do
you follow and look at all of their
content I think the biggest trend is
community your community doesn't have to
be large for you to be able to survive
in a social media recession you could
create a real business with under 500.
whatever platform you're on that's the
move
if you've been noticing that your views
are going down your engagement your
likes are going down you're not alone
everything is changing in social media
there's a lot of trends that are dead
and they just do not work anymore and
there's a lot of new things that you
need to know if you ultimately want to
not just grow your following but grow
your business generate sales and make an
impact in more people's lives so today
we have chalene Johnson back on the
think media podcast she's a New York
Times best-selling author the founder
and creator of the marketing impact
Academy and she's going to be dropping
some free game about how to get your
social media right right now chalene
how's it going dude how do you do that
without notes like you just riff that
you are a unicorn I mean I got lucky but
uh I also I mean I've known you now it's
like eight nine years yeah we're coming
up on our decade wow we should throw a
party we should throw a party yeah like
a vow renewal that would be awesome
and uh and I'm so grateful for you
because you love social media you study
it at a high level and you are I know
people don't like the term influencer
you're in Instagram or all these
followers and all this stuff you've
built up your platform but you're a real
business owner you're a real
entrepreneur that ties the social media
world into customer sales leads but you
understand all these Divergent worlds
and can bring some clarity in the chaos
that we're experiencing right now that's
what it is too it's chaos yeah it's just
wild out there and I know people a lot
frustrated what worked in the past isn't
working right now so I want to actually
tackle some trends that have died before
we get into uh some things that are
working and how do we really build our
business on social but uh what are some
dead trends that you're noticing how do
you feel about
um celebrity influencer endorsements
they're not doing well I mean if you
look at big Brands they and by the way
there's exceptions to everything right
there's some celebrities who they touch
it and it sells out immediately but now
brands are looking at how they're
spending their dollars and they have so
much a much easier time working with
people with a smaller following who have
a very loyal community that listens to
them and believes them and doesn't see
them as this kind of like sellout
celebrity kind of thing so the
celebrities are not getting their Big
Brand deals anymore because those
dollars are being spent on you know
micro and Nano influencers and Define a
micro Nano influencer well I don't think
anybody for whatever reason wants to be
called an influencer anymore it has like
this really negative connotation but
basically if you've got more than a
hundred people that are following you
and interacting right and they're real
people then you've got some influence
and that means that brands are looking
at you like okay does this person have a
good relationship with the people who
are communicating with them is their
trust there and they would much rather
do you know hundreds of Nano influencer
deals versus one big Mega influencer
deal where the that person's hard to
work with their rates are ridiculous uh
you can't tell if they've bought half
their followers the engagement isn't
real so they would much rather work with
these people who are more authentic yeah
that's really good news we talk a lot
for small YouTube creators or smaller
channels or across the platforms micro
Nano influencers or where Brands want to
invest their dollars and the influencer
marketing industry the last numbers we
were looking at was close to 20 billion
and growing about 20 percent a year
that's just that vertical there's so
many different ways to make money just
that one vertical is massive money
flowing into the system so that's
actually a good news dead Trend that the
money is going to Everyday creators how
about
um on Instagram and other vertical
platforms where people are lip syncing
pointing at words and kind of dancing
around I hate to I mean sometimes it
will work but rarely because how often
do you just swipe past that and if we're
talking about monetizing your social
media you've got to get people to know
like and trust you I don't know you if
I'm not not even hearing your voice
you're using someone else's voice you're
pointing to words on the screen and
listen I still do it sometimes because
I'm being lazy it's super easy to create
that kind of content so I don't want to
discourage someone who's like oh man I
just found the courage to do this then
continue but eventually we need to know
who you are and we need to hear your
voice and the consumer is kind of sick
of the copycat Trend which really works
like that's how Tick Tock took off like
there was a trend and then everybody
copied the trend you'd see like 50 000
versions of that same Trend and now
people are like I got it like let's see
something real so best practice in
today's world is talk to camera get on
camera if we're going vertical video and
social media and deliver some value
um and value isn't enough okay I mean it
used to be so that's another dead Trend
so another dead trend is just providing
value yes unfortunately so what's the
next level the next level is how do you
provide value that captivates the entire
time so like really thinking about just
like you do on YouTube what is the very
first sentence that I'm going to say on
Instagram and uh Tick Tock and you know
any of these short form platforms used
to be able to just like create some
great content and there was a hook in
there someplace but now you literally
you've got three seconds so you that
extra breath is a moment where you might
lose some and they're swiping so it's
really putting thought in up leveling
your content because everyone's your mom
is creating content you know what I mean
so it's like there's so much Supply and
very little demand so you have to up
level that means if you're going to
provide value it also has you've got to
think about how can I Captivate and and
part of that is also
entertaining and so you'd call it uh
edutainment it would education with
entertainment but something that's make
it more interesting you you have the
environment you're filming in visuals I
mean because I've seen some people who
are like not entertaining people in real
life I just know because I've met them
yeah and but their content's super
entertaining because they found a really
great editor or maybe they're doing it
themselves hopefully they're Outsourcing
that but you know you you can take any
piece of content a professor delivering
a lecture and if it's edited the right
way it's entertaining how about the
metaverse what about the metaverse that
word scares me what is that I know I
don't know do you think it's a big Trend
this year or do you think it's kind of
dead for now I don't think that it's the
place that people are focusing on no I
don't you know I think for entrepreneurs
like in terms of Saving Time and even
just like writing captions and coming up
with great titles and even content ideas
artificial intelligence oh my God like
freaking Game Changer like just for that
person's like I'm not creative I can't
come up with ideas I've just got the
script but I don't know how to make my
first sentence interesting throw it into
chat GPT or an AI platform and say tell
me what's the most interesting sentence
to start this paragraph off so I hook my
viewers so a dead trend is humans that
are not enhanced by artificial
intelligence basically if you are not if
you are just oh I don't want to use it I
don't want to leverage it I think the
quote that's been going around is
artificial intelligence isn't going to
replace you somebody using artificial
intelligence is going to replace you
facts and get and it's a skill to use it
like you just you know whenever whatever
you put in as a prompt you're what
you're going to get back is like okay
but then you just keep refining it
refining it refining it the next thing
you know you're like did I write this
I'm a genius you know what I mean yes so
it's it's being patient what do you
think about nfts I know nothing about
them yeah they don't interest me at all
like I I'm like a la la la la so that's
what I know about FTS Brock Johnson was
mentioning that his Instagram backed off
on their nfts and originally you know
there's a news because I was like guys
this is boring right and there's a new
but the Market's also crashed uh the
value and there's been a lot of low
trust level in them because there were
so many scams I just didn't get it
anytime someone described it to me I'm
like but that doesn't make sense yeah
and uh not only that but the new the
Susan the CEO of YouTube left was
replaced by a new guy and some of the
mistrust for him was like YouTube's
going all in on nfts and it's all kind
of dissolved so I think that's probably
another dead Trend probably not forever
but at least for now as with all Trends
right sometimes they do cycle back and
that's why you have to tune into experts
so that you don't have to figure it out
like watching the show and when you have
an expert it's like Outsourcing that
side of your business because you do
this stuff is a game changer like you
have such an advantage if you understand
what trends are what trends are dying
and what's about to happen so you can
innovate yes and so speaking now of
we've been talking kind about what's
what's not working with everything
that's changing in social media and what
is working well I think it's important
to talk about the fact that we're we're
in a social media recession and there is
an inordinate number of people who are
just now producing content your mom your
cousin like everyone has multiple
accounts they're creating content
everyone wants to be a get Podcast deals
or sponsorship or become a nano
influencer so there's an unbelievable
Supply and statistically speaking people
want to consume less we don't want to
spend as much time on social so we want
to follow us so we're it's just like a
recession in the economy when there's
you know people don't have enough money
I.E time and there's a huge supply then
what you're going to see is people are
very choosy about how they're spending
and they're spending their time on the
very few creators who actually deliver
right so because of that if you know
that and just think about your own human
nature how many people do you follow and
look at all of their content very few
right and you probably follow thousands
of people at least hundreds and maybe
you look at between five and eight of
them per day so how do you become one of
those five or eight you do that by
understanding human nature it's if
you're getting fewer likes less
engagement fewer followers you're not
doing something wrong that's we just
have so much Supply so how do you combat
that what's the trend the trend is to be
Innovative to adapt to not follow the
trends to to notice what you're not
interested in anymore on social and stop
producing that like even though
everyone's producing the same kind of
thing and you're like this is so boring
or dumb then don't do that you know even
though it's it seems like it's popular
it's not it's dying by the time you're
sick of it it's dying so innovate be
creative I think the biggest trend is
community you know we were just talking
about music right like when people uh
back in the day you buy an album me
listen to every single song over and
over and over again now you hear someone
you know dropped a new album and you you
listen to the hit and then you move on
and that's it yeah unless you you're
like that's your dude right like Drake
just dropped a new album I'm gonna
listen to every single song you know and
memorize the words because you're you
belong there right like so I think
creating community in our social is so
underrated that's huge I know that uh
our mutual friend Pat Flynn who's also
one of the instructors in the marketing
impact Academy yeah
um wrote a book called super fans loved
it super fans is The Edge and what's
kind of funny is thinking about dead
Trends or new trends Community you could
call it a new trend but there's a book
called raving fans oh yeah that's maybe
20 30 years old yeah raving fans is the
essence of any real business yes if you
can actually make deeper connections and
then you your community doesn't have to
be large for you to be able to survive
in a social media recession if you have
a thousand true fans then anything's
possible and you could weather any
storms in a thousand today you know I
think if they were to rewrite repo wish
that book it'd be less than a thousand I
think you could you could create a real
business with under 500. if you're
really tapping into your community right
and I think that's what a lot of people
Miss because they're focused on getting
that viral video and when you focus on
going viral what happens is you follow a
trend and you get all these people to
follow you or at least see your content
and they don't follow you because the
rest of your content doesn't deliver
that same thing that Niche it doesn't
provide value that's entertaining on
that same particular topic people are
very topic focused we want we have a
problem that we need to solve and that's
why I'm following you that's why I
subscribe to your YouTube channel that's
why I continually watch your content is
there an example that comes to mind of a
business or a brand your own or somebody
else's that has innovated or pivoted in
this recession and something that
they're doing
um recently yeah well I would not to
toot my own horn but I really did a big
pivot I don't care about growing having
even one more new follower honest even
though I teach Instagram and I tell
people don't do what I do if you're
looking for more followers I'm not I'm
like I have over 760
000 followers why do I need another one
I don't know the people who are
following me and I I just want to make
sure they're consuming my content I have
a relationship with them so I just focus
now really my strategy there is to
really connect on stories and I spend a
lot more time in my DMs than I do
thinking like okay what should be the
next reel that I post or is this you
know cool or interesting am I going to
get new followers is this going to go
viral I don't care because because I
built it right so now I want to get to
know them that's interesting and by
spending more time in your DMs you're
spending more time going deeper with the
people who are already there rather than
being in this Pursuit and desperate
cling for new people or more people or
going viral yeah and desperate's a word
I think we all and I can say we've all
feel that way sometimes where you're
like you look at other people's content
and sometimes it's dumb content where
you're like how is this going going
viral and you're like okay I'm going to
do something dumb too and it just
doesn't work and then you start to
question yourself and you go on this
Loop where you're looking at other and
then you're like okay I'm going to quit
I'm done with social media I hate it but
if you just stay don't worry about those
metrics like do not worry about those
vanity metrics and you really just think
about like how can I entertain uh
provide value but also a lot of people
know who I am and those and just keep
pouring into my community every day I'll
hear from students who are like I can't
get people to talk to me or engage with
me in my social you know whether it's
YouTube or Tick Tock or Instagram and
when I go and look at their content it's
almost always because they're it's
monologue Style
you know where they're just like talking
at them as opposed to bringing them in
getting their feedback asking their
opinions delivering content because they
asked for it and then also saying the
reason why I've just created this for
you like nothing I do in my business has
anything to do with my hair right but in
my DMs yesterday all day long people
like will you show us how you do your
hair show us how you do your hair I'm
like all right that has nothing to do
with my Niche but I created a reel today
showing people how I style my hair
because I'm pouring into my existing
followers and that's what they ask for
and I want them to look at me as like
I'm their you know their girlfriend
their BFF yeah that's powerful now
um I want to talk about how to actually
monetize on social a lot of creators are
focusing on the wrong things yes now
we're also only gonna be able to cover
so much and we're going to co-host a
free class and that's at idea to income
dot tips if you want to register
entirely entirely free you're really
doing the heavy lifting you've got a
whole presentation and uh I remember I
love your trainings you've done many for
our community you spoke at vidsummit uh
a while back crushed that session and so
you just pack it so full of value so I
just want to make sure that's on
people's radar yeah idea to income dot
tips if you want to register for that
free training when it comes to most
people focusing on social media and
trying to make money everybody thinks
they need a million followers they need
to go viral they are hoping that reels
meta pays them even though they just
pulled that away yeah they're hoping to
get monetized on YouTube even though
unless you're massive it kind of just
pays pennies so it's not very practical
and so what is where are people missing
it in terms of their philosophy of
actually making money on social media
you know and that's why I'm doing this
Workshop because we want this to be
super simple and it's it's not that
there are levels to it it's not just
what you're seeing like we see someone
who's got a large YouTube following a
large Instagram following getting a lot
of likes and we just that's how they're
making money but it's not right and and
so it's teaching people how much they're
leaving on the table and number one so
how to set up a foundation so that if
you do get approached by somebody who
wants to offer you a brand deal or a
paid post do you already know how to
position yourself do you already know
how to disclose or pitch your rates do
you already have if someone is looking
at your viral video or I we call it
viral for me right so if you have a
video that goes viral for you meaning
it's it gets 50 more views and what you
get on a normal piece of content like so
that's a really good piece of content
for you what do you do with those people
when they look at it how do you they may
never come back so how do you capture
them it's understanding like the things
you have to set up like an email list
understanding retargeting understanding
how you can once you've got someone's
attention it's the most valuable thing
you could have don't let them just walk
out the door right so I like to teach
people what do those Basics look like
because they're not that hard but no one
talks about it it's all gay kept you
know and and maybe it's not gay cap
maybe just be people find it boring but
if you don't do it yes you're not going
to make money I mean the chances are of
you making a business out of your social
media is pretty sketch yes and a
sustainable business as well because for
a lot of people content creators
quote-unquote influencers or even
entrepreneurs that dip their toes in the
social media game it's kind of feast or
famine or 15 minutes of fame a lot of
people are here today gone tomorrow yeah
it's interesting as as one of the
reasons why you're such a mentor to me
is because you have stood the test of
time and continue to reinvent yourself
you've weathered every economic the
highs and the lows because you've built
a real business and I think that there's
a lot to learn there so I'm excited for
that Master Class coming out but I
wanted to point out one thing you
mentioned because I have a confession to
make you mentioned what you always say
vfm viral for me and our think media
podcast listeners and our VRA Community
would know that that's one of the things
I've stolen from you so so I have taught
vfm to our community one of the other
ones I say all the time I'm like listen
you got to be brief be bright be fine
and that's probably one of like scared
money don't make money you know who did
you steal uh the riches are in the
niches from I don't think is that one
even stealable I don't know who could
have said that my son gives you credit
for it all the time oh there's no way
that way yeah you get credit for a lot
of things that's just one of those
technically it's niches so it's the
riches are in the niches but it's it
only works and everybody gets offended
if they don't live in the U.S where we
say Niche yeah the riches are in the
niches but that one I don't that's one
of those ones that's been so stolen yeah
still so true it is so true still so
true so if any more comes to mind but
what people will begin to realize is
that you know your Frameworks and all of
these strong principles that you teach
are really concrete and that's why uh by
trying to simplify because it can be
super duper overwhelming and as you know
you know I've got extreme ADHD so this
stuff could would really overwhelm me
and complicate me like there's all these
things I'm supposed to be doing all at
once my executive function dysfunctions
and I don't know which one to do first
so I try to do all of them and I've just
learned especially in business that you
have to slow down and go okay there's a
step one there's just what I do second
would I do third because I can't do all
these things at once if I do I'll fail
and then I feel defeated so um because I
struggle with that I think I'm good at
simplifying these things even though
sometimes I like to make it easy even
though sometimes the
um the content it it just requires
someone breaking it down in simple steps
yeah I love that so speaking of
monetization and you're talking about
some of these steps one of the biggest
steps that was kind of funny because I
had been trying to grow on social media
from 2007 was when I first started a a
YouTube channel for my church that's
super early days
2010 think media starts I had my video
production Stan uh Channel and I had my
personal Channel where I was doing a lot
of random Mainland YouTube vlog Vlogs
cooking videos movie reviews all this
random stuff and so now I'm doing my
best to absorb learnings and education
from people but for 2010 to 2015 made a
little money with ranking videos and
affiliate marketing but then I
discovered your podcast build your tribe
and then eventually I joined your
program the marketing impact Academy but
and then you became a professor and then
became a professor in the marketing
impact Academy and but one of the things
that multiple episodes on build your
tribe just started to revolutionize my
thinking was you started saying you need
to build an email list also not super
sexy wasn't like oh right like let's go
I'm pumped like you know because I want
to go make a video or I want to go Vlog
with my wife and our dogs down in Laguna
Beach at the time you know and and and
and kind of go do fun stuff but there's
also these practical things and and that
changed everything and even today brand
new stats 2023 came out about how email
marketing is the most effective way to
get your met to actually Reach people
when algorithms are so fickle why do you
encourage people to build an email list
it's it's crazy that that is still the
thing you know I if you would have asked
me 10 years ago if I thought that would
be the case 10 years later I would say
I'm not sure but like yesterday I met
with um some you know big YouTubers who
they start a podcast like uh nine years
ago and two years ago they started doing
a YouTube channel right and they're like
that's when we realized like we have to
we've got to build our email list and he
said two things happened first of all
people found them on YouTube their
podcast and and then secondly they start
to truly monetize because they focus on
their email list and um recently they
were just approached by a major player
Spotify reached out to them to acquire
them for a deal that is a pretty hefty
eight figures wow it to go exclusive on
Spotify and they declined because and
Spotify was like what yeah low you know
do you know who we are but they just say
that because you can't you don't see
that you don't see an email list I mean
I don't talk about my email list I but
I'm building it every single day in
Social every story not every story but
every day I'm doing something on stories
that's intentionally working to to reach
that person who's like I want more I
want I'm not here for the FL the haircut
I want to go I want to learn more I want
to go deeper and I want to be able to
serve those people and then it's really
knowing how to deliver an email that
people are going to open yeah well
that's we could spin off on that these
days I think media we're talking about
open rates and deliverability and
subject lines and copies fascinating
stuff and uh the different service
providers and and the nuances of
deliverability that they have and
they're yeah you can get pretty deep so
so so I have to say this I can't tell
you because I got hacked in 2015 right
so for whatever reason my name gets
passed around to everybody in social
media celebrities I've had like people
on TV shows have their agents reach out
to me so and so got hacked the people
who are the most freaked out when they
reach out to me are the people who have
built an Empire
in Social and they are devastated
because they've got a notification from
let's say Instagram violation of
community guidelines account is gone
which means money is gone sponsorship's
gone like it's all gone because they
didn't build those foundational pieces
there you asked me earlier can you
there's so many people probably three a
week I hear from people who are like I
had the two-factor authentication I I
was using
um password protected software I was
doing all the things we had two-factor
authentication all the things and I
still got hacked or I still lost my
account or I still fill in the blank and
then
every once in a while I hear from
someone that says but it's okay because
I have I've got my email list and so I
can rebuild it and I and I I still have
a way to make income so it isn't sexy
but neither is opening up a bank account
neither is you know doing some of the
things that are it's adulting and if
you're on social media this is the adult
thing you need to do man that is so
powerful and what are some tips you know
think media got hacked think media
podcast this YouTube channel that this
episode will be on
we had to Factor on it was probably
cookie hijacking it was Tesla official
or Tesla CEO where they started
streaming Elon Musk to scam crypto
they've used a Google Titan key on their
end as soon as they got our us out of it
so then it was like they were the ones
that had the authority and then for 10
days our ad Revenue went to zero we
couldn't upload obviously and and one
grateful it wasn't our main channel two
big wake-up call three I was still able
to sleep good at night because of AR
email list our actual business
diversification of our brand it is so
scary and it's such a violation yeah
like I remember the pit in the bottom of
my stomach like huge you feel like
someone has broken into your home it is
the weirdest feeling and I hear from
people all the time they're like no one
would I'm not of Interest I've got 200
followers or whatever I'm like no you
you are an identity so you are of
interest you are value and a lot of
times these schemes are aimed at people
who have a big falling but
the the people get these huge numbers
when we're looking at the statistics of
people are hacked on a daily basis it's
just random what are some of your quick
tips a couple topics I want to hit as we
land the plane which is famous last
words when I'm close to Landing the
plane but uh but just a few tips on
um keep yourself safe that you've
learned I also want to hear about
patreon we get a lot of questions about
that you're a patreon legend yeah thanks
for some people they they have struggled
getting that off the ground YouTube
Partner uh Channel memberships and then
maybe just touching on a little bit of
what you're gonna do obviously people
can go to the class and that's there's
so much to cover uh but even why
building a team or things like that are
so critical to really create an edge
eventually as you build your social
media business but speak to some of
those practical things yeah what two
things that I think are important to
connect our team and protecting yourself
okay because more often than not
especially today the people that I'm
hearing from who have lost their account
it's they were doing everything right
but they had given access to a team
member or or a team member accidentally
clicked on a link or a team member
accidentally gave Etc so I would say you
know there's Basics like the basics are
two-factor authentication the basics are
using some type of authentication app
versus having those numbers or codes
sent directly to your phone um because
what's an authentication like a Google
authentication app it you just when
you're logging into say YouTube or
Instagram
you pull up that app and it will
generate a code for you that expires
within I think 30 seconds and then you
plug it into your whatever instead of
getting text because if if they had your
Apple ID or hack your Apple ID they can
get the code that's texting you that's
right and and that's what happens to a
lot of people they don't realize that
they're like I got it back and then I
lost it again that's why um they're just
there's so many steps ahead of us that
you just need to do the basics like use
an authentication app always use a
password manager don't think I've got
really great passwords and I keep them
on my my phone note I I put them up if
you're my dad I put on a little Post-It
note on the top of my laptop yeah you
know yeah so you've got to use that and
then you have to make sure your entire
team does yeah and almost all of those
apps are low cost and you just it's a
mandatory thing nobody on my team
touches any accounts unless they're
using the app where everything is
authenticated and so team also could
mean agency it could also third-party
apps are kind of scary because if if
something is logged into your YouTube
channel via third-party app and that
gets hacked that is actually a
vulnerability point which I haven't
heard meant much of that I haven't heard
much of that either but think about it
they do say yeah because you say you
know do you trust this account that
you're allowing to you know so those are
some great tips uh we'll come back to
building it a little bit about getting a
team around this but but what are you
guys doing on patreon fun so that that
to me is really Community right so that
is um you think about the people when
I'm creating long-form content on
podcasts so I've got a business podcast
and then I have a personal podcast it's
lifestyle it's Health Etc um we just
talk about everything lifestyle and and
there I just found I've got some people
listen to the show that just want more
of the personal stuff like really want
the off the Record how do you really
feel kind of thing which maybe isn't
valuable to somebody else but it's
interesting or entertaining to to a
certain segment of your population and
so we created a patreon and it's just so
fun because they are you like it's like
your deepest friends or your CL you're
raving fans right yes and um so that's
fun it's super low production I
literally grab my phone I don't even use
a microphone I record it while I'm in my
car I record it while I'm trying on like
I record it while I'm putting on my
makeup so it's like they're spending
time with me they know it's not scripted
it's completely authentic it's the stuff
that I don't feel appropriate putting on
the regular show and it's fun but most
importantly it builds this solid
community of people that belong you know
people are looking for a place to belong
and when you you know when people are
not paying content creators whether it's
on Instagram now has subscription I'm
sure tick tock's going to follow
YouTube's doing their own thing too and
I think that is that's the move man
whatever platform you're on that's the
move yeah Community taking that place
where you're moving them from whatever
platform to someplace deeper
um that's very fascinating and speak to
I will say this about the patreon app
it's janky like it's not great yeah and
I'm like how they're making millions and
millions like how are they not improving
this platform it works great for the end
user yeah but as a Creator I'm like how
this is funky so I hope it improves or
they'll get put out of business somebody
else will take over and there are I'm
off the top of my I mean Channel
memberships Channel memberships from
YouTube's kind of a bummer they take 30
30 yeah patreon takes like five yeah and
I know there's some other Alternatives
but the idea of building community so
powerful all right building a team like
all the way back to Trends are dying
things are changed changing business
owners are listening to this
entrepreneurs that want to build their
personal brand they want to get into
social media what what's building a team
Riff on that yeah I would think the
first thing you have to do is don't
think about building a team think about
hiring one one part-time temporary
person like you just need help you you
just need help like you can't be doing
all this stuff yourself and especially
because now I think another Trend we're
going to see is moving away from
quantity right like you gotta post more
you gotta you know more and more and
more I think people are like nah I want
better you know so in order to produce
better content that means better editing
and I don't know about you but I don't I
want to do the research to create the
best content I don't want to do the
research and spend all the time editing
when there are people who can do that at
a fraction of what it would cost me to
spend my time doing that and they're
going to do it better so it's like even
just consider batch creating some
content and finding somebody who will
edit some reels for you or edit some
YouTube sure sports or edit some tick
tocks or just me maybe even taking a
look here's here's the way I would let
me just give you a quick takeaway do
this all right go on to upwork.com and
uh or Fiverr
f-i-v-e-r-rr.com and hire somebody to
take the videos or the content you've
already produced in the last six months
that did well your best performing
content send it to them and say re-edit
this make it better make it more
captivating put the hook at the front
and you're going to get content you can
you can produce that again it's already
proven and now it's going to perform
even better you won't have to spend any
time zero time you have to create the
content you have to edit it and you'll
be shocked at how much that will do for
your growth and your brand and your
mental health like being an entrepreneur
trying to grow on social media all these
things it can kill you like if you're
not smart about figuring out who is the
first person you need to delegate to to
help you and don't think of it as a
full-time thing just pay project by
project that's super powerful and
speaking of when you're in a social
media recession when you're trying to
raise the level it's going to be very
difficult to raise the level by yourself
dude when somebody else is potentially
we're not talking about having to break
the bank here no you and deeper in your
programs you teach about Outsourcing and
how affordable that can be and part of
it's also systems the right tools the
right systems the right people and it's
not the I've seen the limiting belief
I've had the limiting belief of okay so
I gotta hire somebody for a sixty
thousand dollar a year salary yeah
they're a W-2 employee I have to play
employment taxes I need a health care
plan probably if I'm even gonna get this
person right I probably need an office
that they'll come and you just like a
lunchroom you spin off yeah I'm gonna
have to stock the snack bar and it's
like no you could hire somebody for 10
hours legit like and and that when you
do the actual economics and math as you
say scared money don't make money and we
break that down for our students our
members inside marketing impact Academy
A lot of times when they join they they
don't have a business yet they just are
like kind of scared about this idea I'm
not sure if it would work you know I
don't know if this is my thing and one
of the first things we teach them is how
to hire and they're like wait why would
I hire anyone I'm not making any money
and I can't afford to do that you know
I've just invested in this program like
how are you expecting me to hire anyone
and we break it down for them so that
they understand like no it's it's not
hiring a full-time person that I don't
know very many people that would yeah
it's who do you need right now so you
can start making money what's the
minimum amount of money that you can
spend let me show you where to hire them
where to find them how to write the ad
how to interview them how to vet their
their their portfolio how to know how
are you supposed to pay them what's the
right going rate depending on what
country they're in all of those things
people don't know unless you know you
teach them how to do those and who's the
first higher second higher third hire
what do I do if I I do want somebody
full-time like all of those things are
you know having been in business for 30
years been there done that so I want to
know the opportunity that awaits us
there's definitely some challenges in
front of us but what is the opportunity
that's also ahead and well we will land
the plane with that but just as a
reminder chalene is going to be teaching
a deep dive class all about where social
media is today how do you actually
capture attention and how more tactical
advice on how to thrive in any economy
with what's working right now and
specifically going deeper with
monetization so it's going to be power
packed you can check out the show notes
for a link to register it's entirely
free or just go to
www.ideatoincome.tips to register for
that and are we still saying www because
it stops off camera I know and that was
for my mom I don't love URLs that are
not.com but because it's dot tips that's
kind of like okay I'm glad you said that
because my brain missed that I was so
focused on the WWE exactly so so to know
that this this is a URL that will take
you to register for this free class www
casemate idea to income dot tips um or
just go to the show notes and use that
link but all that to say is there's many
challenges but what do you see as the
opportunity ahead for leaning in I think
it's awesome because what is another
Trend that's just dead is the Perfection
stuff like oh my God such as a woman so
annoying so triggering so like Ugh throw
I want to throw up at some of the stuff
that you felt like you had to post
before right and how perfect your house
had to be a certain aesthetic and your
kids had to match it like you know none
of it made any sense to me and you know
I have to be like a bro standing in
front of my Rolls-Royce like none of
that stuff works and um so you know
pretty privilege all that stuff goes by
the wayside people want real and that is
awesome because it's so much easier to
remember like to keep track of who you
are if you're just who you are as
opposed to putting on this like social
media persona pretending and editing and
it's getting a backlash people don't
want to see that they want legit real
and if you know how to be real that's a
huge opportunity and it's a lot easier
wow I love that advice chalene Johnson
you're teaching the class that'll be in
the show notes but if people want to
follow you and connect with you how can
they connect with you well I'd love to
invite them to listen to either podcast
the chalene show is my lifestyle stuff
that's good comedy there and then build
your tribe is my son Brock and I and
that's just business stuff like we try
to be brief bright and make it fun and
then we're just done yes I love it thank
you so much for adding so much value
today thank you it's fun